bom eu sou médica e na verdade em 2012
eu estudava oncologia no rio de janeiro
enquanto não estava preocupado em fazer
um monte de quimioterapia
o que mais me incomodava é que eu
comecei a perceber que o processo de
adoecer era muito pior do que a doença
em si
a gente sofria muito mais dos serviços
de saúde que estavam ao redor do que do
câncer por si só e eu resolvi tomar um
caminho um pouquinho diferente
eu comecei e da inovação eu larguei
oncologia e comecei a fazer um esforço
de inovação no rio de janeiro e um dos
cursos
a gente tinha um desafio onde é óbvio
que eu era a única médica que fazer
aquilo e tinha um problema a gente
precisava resolver alguma solução para a
mobilidade urbana no brasil
o meu grupo eu adorava andar de
bicicleta e nem usava muito mas eu
gostava de ir de bicicleta para a praia
assim no rio de janeiro
e eu tinha que atravessar a lagoa e eu
comecei a ver como é que a gente usava
alguma coisa foi a primeira vez que eu
comecei a pensar como é que a gente usa
um serviço e aí a gente criou um
aplicativo que era a idéia de mapear as
rotas de bicicleta do rio de janeiro pra
gente conseguir fazer ciclovias no lugar
certo onde as pessoas usam efetivamente
baseada no comportamento das formigas
essa idéia maluca óbvio me levou para
esse programa que é super revolucionário
onde a gente estuda tudo sobre
tecnologias tecnologias exponenciais o
que está acontecendo no mundo que pode
nos ajudar a resolver os principais
problemas da humanidade e desde então eu
já tinha estudado gestão antes e eu
comecei a ver que a gente podia criar
novas idéias novos produtos novos
serviços
ainda mais num momento onde a gente vive
uma revolução aqui a gente chama de
revolução digital
afinal é indiscutível a gente dizer que
o mundo vem mudando
é mercados como música comunicação
comércio educação mobilidade
parece que tudo virou de ponta cabeça
parece que tudo mudou
mas quando a gente pensa no usuário
eu acho que é legal a gente entender o
que é o ser humano porque na verdade eu
acho que esses mercados que foram
desculpados vamos dizer assim
são mercados que se apaixonaram pelas
suas próprias tecnologias e foram
substituídos por outras
na verdade a sony não vende a música ela
vendia discos e vocês acabaram de ser
absoluta prova disso é que não importa a
forma como a gente escuta música
a emoção é a mesma a grande verdade é
que a tecnologia é uma ferramenta não é
um fim a gente ainda é o mesmo ser
humano que a gente era milhares milhares
de anos atrás
eu acho que a gente continua fazendo
praticamente as mesmas coisas
a gente adora compartilhar as nossas
conquistas
sempre procuramos um norte para nos
guiar pelos mais breves destinos a gente
não mudou muito
nem a self é tão moderna assim
na verdade se a gente não usa a
tecnologia como ferramenta a gente pode
ser substituído por ela porque a gente é
baseado por emoções e em saúde
eu acho muito perigoso porque eu
trabalho em projetos que as empresas
tentam a buscar novas formas de entregar
saúde e é nítido que a gente precisa
fazer alguma coisa diferente no mercado
hoje a gente tem médico paciente o
hospital gestor
até quem não tá no meio de saúde está
reclamando a gente não pode mais fazer
as mesmas coisas da mesma forma que a
gente não precisa fazer as mesmas coisas
da mesma forma a gente tem um monte de
tecnologia absolutamente sensacional que
nos ajudam como ferro
lentas mas eu fiquei um pouco preocupada
eu costumo dizer que até uns dois anos
atrás
é fácil fazer inovação ninguém sabia
muito o que quer acho que até hoje meu
pai está muito bem também
mas a grande verdade é que a gente
precisa aprender e dados novos desafios
saúde ficou perigoso porque a gente como
médico entendeu que a nossa função era
dar diagnósticos fazer tratamentos mas
na verdade isso é ferramenta nós nos
apaixonamos pelas nossas próprias serra
ferramentas e se a gente não cuidar
a gente também pode ser substituído por
elas têm uma piadinha que está rolando
no ataque esses dias que eu achei ótimo
o paciente chega ao consultório e falar
sim doutor tudo bem eu vi no google e eu
queria uma segunda opinião de um médico
com um pouquinho de raiva fala assim
pergunta para o yahoo
é um fato a gente não sabe lidar com
isso gente
eu fui formada para dizer assim vêm até
mim eu vou te dar resposta mas a grande
verdade é que a gente não tem as
respostas
mesmo com supercomputadores o que a
gente tem a probabilidade
a gente continua fazendo a mesma coisa
a gente precisa se conectar com um ser
humano isso é a nossa oportunidade de
ser melhor
a tecnologia não precisa dar medo é aqui
que a gente melhora não existe nenhuma
civilização no mundo que não tenha uma
figura de um cuidador é aqui que a gente
faz a diferença seja ele um pajé seja
ele um curandeiro seja ele um médico
seja ele uma mãe
o ritual do cuidado ele é insubstituível
ele é ancestral ele faz parte da nossa
cultura
a tecnologia é a ferramenta que a gente
pode potencializar o nosso potencial
como cuidador viagem só acreditar na
nossa própria tecnologia
não há dúvidas que a gente vai ser
substituído por elas
a gente precisa é de tecnologia que
demonstre respeito
respeito é tempo e individualidade
a gente precisa de ferramentas que
demonstrem confiança
isso é transparência e eficiência de
comunicação ea gente precisa de
comprometimento isso é atitude de
solucionar problemas
se a gente não começar a colocar o
paciente no centro de todos os nossos
projetos e redesenhar os serviços de
saúde
não adianta investir em tecnologia
tecnologia é ferramenta tecnologia é
ferramenta dados ajudam a melhorar
processos
agora o sofrimento é só com as mãos
agora tá nas mãos de vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]